I think we're in line and that what
advice do you have for someone that's
going to pull the cord and and jump free
from a job that brought in a lot of
money a lot of prestige a lot of people
would think wow that's great you know
you're on Wall Street you're running a
hedge fund and then you're you're saying
no I want to make an independent film
now and I'm gonna I'm gonna break free
of this life it's just like Michael
judge said to me he said think about
what the world would be like if people
did what they were afraid to do I mean
so yeah sure there's a safety blanket
and but that what kind of life is that
you know i am when i was at film school
i would be editing a film that I shot
and I would look at my watch and it was
like eight hours went by and it felt
like 10 minutes and that's the kind of
feeling that you know they say if you
love what you do you don't work a day in
your life or something like that so you
know it take a leap you know what I mean
or else just live your whole life doing
something you hate to do and being
afraid to that's no life you know yeah
right but in the real world too though
there's like an invisibility factor
sometimes when you switch over to a
creative thing that hasn't totally taken
off and when you're on Wall Street and
you have a title you know you're
respected you know so how was that
thinking almost like maybe there's going
to be a stigma attached to me leaving
something um you mean in terms of it
being sort of a humbling experience to
start at the bottom a little bit because
it sounds a lot of people when they do
that sort of switch of careers it's not
just going from one great position to
another there's there's oh for sure yeah
you know I I just it for me it got to
the point and remember it took another
five years basically for me to finally
so typically with me I don't really do
anything until my backs against the wall
you know like that's just the way I am
so not doing it just got too
overwhelming for me so for me i I just
was thinking like you know I don't want
to live the rest of my life thinking
what if I had tried this kind of things
so I just think
it you know can you tell me what
you mean by backs against the wall in
this situation like was it just wear
like you're basically in the office and
times I was miserable Karen I mean I was
miserable you know so it's not about the
outside stuff you know the apartment and
the cars and whatever it is it's like if
you're not happy i mean that's that's
you know and I knew there's a quote i
think it's lorca he says something like
to burn with desire and keep quiet about
it is the greatest punishment we can get
you know put upon ourselves and it's so
true you know I it's just it's after a
while of just being like what if and let
me try Plus technology caught up to you
know people guys are making clerks and
brothers McMullen and like that it
was like I can do this let me just try
it so yeah that's whatever so what's
your advice for someone else in your
same position may be there a doctor
lawyer whatever may be there physical
therapist whatever it is where it's like
there's a title there's a respect factor
their family thinks oh he's doing great
our son is this he's amazing and turns
out our son doesn't want to be there
sure I think it shouldn't be free you
know our son doesn't want to be I think
should be that per the Sun itself saying
to himself I don't want to be here a but
be it doesn't have to be all or nothing
to you know remember i wrote a script
when i was still working on Wall Street
so it doesn't have to be like I quit and
let me try this jump into this whole
thing it depends on what the endeavor is
but if somebody wants to be an actor or
write or whatever you don't have to quit
your job and chained up and everything
so I guess my advice would be in general
pull that trigger whatever that trigger
is for you but you know you can sort of
dip your toe in the water a little bit
yeah for sure but you know wondering
about something like seeing a girl and
wanting to ask her out I'm just and she
never liked I speaking for myself that's
happened to me you know I've seen a girl
like I'd love to talk to her and she I
never talked to her so after a while
you're like okay I don't want to feel
that feeling again let me talk to her
this time you do and you know whatever
happens right so I think not doing
something for me at least is I have to
just kind of keep doing it that's what I
sort of mean about back against the wall
you